là le français toujours une langue
vivante et bien ceux qui font le plus
vivre la langue qui joue les plus secs
les mots bien sûr ce sont les jeunes
je propose maintenant de les retrouver
dans un lycée parisien lycée du 15e
arrondissement et vous allez voir
comment il joue avec les mots quels sont
les mots les jeunes emploi maintenant
comment tu te sens devant la caméra
je me sens mal parce que j'ai
l'impression d'être devant dès condé on
est surveillé quoi les condés et conduit
des keufs quoi on a les glandes
ah oui ça on a les boules c'est une
expression qui veut dire que c'est pas
bien quoi le contraire avoir du plaisir
c'est comme on dit ça je me la donne
quoi c'est d'abord du plaisir je me la
donne je m'amuse je mettrais situe
amoureux d'une fille appui lui dit
comment tu croques je suis morgan d'une
fille d'une gadji plus tôt
gadji wayne gadji et ça existe au
masculin c'est moi la wii gadjo craignos
où ça te regarde quelque chose chouf
tchouf témoin demain maintenant tu m'as
tu m'as tu mates on peut dire je chauffe
du chauffage ou non pendant on dit
simplement je souffre je voulais un
impératif jusqu'à des mots autrement
qu'ils sont elles très à la mode
voilà ce qu'a rapporté pour désignant un
gadjo un homme hamas car cela donnait
aussi c'est ça la voix sur est assurée
assure et assurer leur avenir assuré sur
le jour assure pas trop quoi
là c'est sûr pas vraiment pour les
caméras c'est pas mal à l'aise un peu et
quand ils y restent pendant quinze ans
plus de longs doigts sur uniquement en
fait deux morts